the debut of vegan cheese didn't inspire
confidence
it was weird
the mouth feel is like a play-dohy
mouthfeel but in the years since vegan
cheese has gone from this oh yeah it
really tastes like cheese no it doesn't
to a grocery store staple
i wouldn't know this wasn't cheap i'm
pretty impressed but vegan cheese
despite innovations and tastes and
creativity in recipes still has a
problem there is no great plant-based
cheese that will melt stretch that will
bubble that will brown so what's the
science behind why vegan cheese doesn't
act like we expect
[Music]
the problem is this tiny protein
casein
wired to talk to two cheese researchers
to explain the science behind vegan
cheese it's not found anywhere else in
the natural world only in the milk of
mammals so what that really means is
that mimicking casein or replacing
casein with a plant-based protein or
some other plant-based ingredient
is extremely extremely challenging or
nearly impossible a lot has changed
since these videos were made
improvements to plant-based fermentation
the use of new bacterial cultures and
cheese aging techniques have created new
varieties of vegan cheeses that smell
taste and look better than previous
versions
but a vegan cheese that acts and melts
like the cheeses we know and love
remains elusive what makes casein really
special and very very unique is that it
is an unusual type of protein each
protein molecule by itself has this
undefined structure if you were able to
go to a really fancy microscope you
would be able to see these casein bowls
but within that bowl we have no clue how
these cases like behave or aggregate or
what their actual shape or form is and
that is what's really unusual about them
compared to any other protein these
cheese variants that are more like
cheese spreads or cream cheese or things
that are eaten like on a cracker and
they don't need to melt or stretch it's
been somewhat easier to recreate those
and that's why plant-based cheeses have
actually had better success the vegan
cheeses on the market run into this
problem
we melted eight different cheeses and
while some did bubble and some even
oozed when folded they didn't melt like
an animal-based cheese did
so what's the next frontier in vegan
cheese science
two startups are tackling the problem in
different ways
first up using a fungal strain to create
casein
the belgium based those vegan cowboys
started a bounty hunt a worldwide call
for a fungal strain that feeds on grass
and makes casein without the cow there
is a bounty of 2.5 million euros
ultimately we would like to produce the
caseins in the
best and the most efficient way when you
then compare
bacteria
with fungal
systems and we know from experience that
fungal systems can more efficiently
produce heterologists proteins
and can also reach higher concentrations
second up using microbes to create
casein the startup new culture in san
francisco is focusing on making a melty
stretchy mozzarella using precise
fermentation
fermentation is a process where we would
grow a microbe or a group of microbes
and in that process they would be eating
food that we're giving to them which is
sugar in a precision fermentation what
is different is that instead of microbe
being fed on sugar and producing like a
lot of different molecules we are
instructing microbe and making it
focused to produce predominantly one
ingredient the casein protein it's a
very like empirical and experimentative
process where we did go through
thousands of microbes by now thousands
of variants their vegan mozzarella isn't
on the market yet but it promises it
will have the same melt and stretch as
cow's milk mozzarella we basically
follow the standard the traditional
cheese making processes that have been
around for thousands of years and then
we adapt them to the way our casein
exactly behaves with other plant-based
ingredients we use there is an enzyme
called rennet and historically it was
actually extracted from animals you add
it to the milk and this enzyme will
basically gonna force the casein to
coagulate and turn into cheese and so
this enzyme rennet itself is for last 30
years made from microbes by using
precision fermentation it's made in a
very similar way that we're using to
make our casein will making a vegan
cheese be enough to persuade cheese
lovers to make the switch to a
plant-based alternative there is some
very emotional response people have to
cheese it's like this indulgence product
whereas with you know yogurt or milk a
functional or health product and people
are just kind of more willing to have
other options people preferentially do
not want to compromise
and that's why we also say we want to
use the same ingredients but then made
in a more sustainable way without
animals so the people have the product
that they love to eat and can also eat
it in the future there is a lot of
problems with the industry itself as
where we're growing animals mostly cows
industrially imposes the need for large
amounts of land and water to be used in
what we're doing by using microbes to
produce casein and to produce dairy
products we will require only a fraction
of land and water that's needed for
making traditional dairy products so
it's really like a no-brainer this is
the technology of the future